Is there any benefit to rotating adaptogens or overlapping them? Is there a way to tell which ones are the best for me?
Well, the best way to tell what adaptogens are best for you is how it makes you feel isn't work for you because it feel like it balances your mood
You know, you're taking adaptogens to balance your formals. You're not taking adaptogens to reduce
Like estrogen and progesterone that you can't know if it's reduced unless you measured it
So you're taking adaptogens to balance your pituitary or thyroid and your adrenal hormones and you're going to
I mean a person's taking adaptogens because
they're tired or they're
You know they have anxiety or they have fatigue or you know, you should go to symptoms
So if you're taking adaptogens and you're not noticing any symptoms, yes, you should rotate adaptogens
And see how those symptoms change if you go well, I don't have any those symptoms
I'm just taking them. Well, then maybe you don't don't ask the drug. Thank you. Maybe you don't need to take it to our existence
Don is the clue to be drug. Thank you, Mark. If you don't find somebody who does
prescribed that if you could be that would be helpful for other people